this is episode 6 of potatoes a hundred
different ways and I'm making Duchess
potatoes paired with a garlic vinegar
Mayo I start by boiling Yukon potatoes
then passing them through a ricer
next I add egg yolks spices cream butter
then whisk this mixture until it's
perfectly smooth
I then pipe the mixture onto a baking
dish and finish it off with an egg wash
the final step for these potatoes is to
bake for 20 minutes until golden brown
and crispy on the outside love the
texture creamy soft crunchy on the top
these are a 10. without the sauce I'd
say it's like a six and a half out of
ten that's my true honest I'm a sauce
person